Hale attended couch here I missed last
week's tie Tuesday but I'm here today
and this week we are going to be
analyzing beer production which is
pretty cool because for my capstone
project we actually are working with a
beer distribution company so I am a
little bit aware of the beer industry
but I am definitely not an expert so we
you know we're gonna load in the data
set already we're gonna load in the data
set I'm just gonna do a library tidy
verse and then we're gonna execute that
I'll call this tidy Tuesday um beer
production okay and for this project I
was a lot I was actually looking at some
other people's tighty Tuesday um work on
this this project and I saw someone was
using the geo facet package or you could
basically make a bunch of like mini
charts and have it represent each like
state so I think that would be kind of a
cool thing to do um I might just try it
out and we can do something pretty
simple for it so we see that there's
actually a beer state so let's first I'm
gonna delete this thing so let's do a
beer States see what's doing on Prem
barrels okay let's do a GG pot x equals
year y equals barrels color equals type
as giome line plus facet wrap state
scales equals three and then end call
with say I don't know and let's do let's
see something even so let's do uh five
columns run that it's gonna be too small
but we're gonna do some tweaking just
okay so theme actually probably won a
position bowls a theme legend dot
position a legend got positioned equal
the top and then fig with equals we'll
say 15 big dot high equals I don't know
probably 20 and let's see what it looks
like okay
my so this isn't really that great of a
plot we could also add like kind of a do
I still have kind of like a cool little
theme option to make a look a little bit
prettier right okay so we have like okay
an economist style I need to change my
scientific options so saipan options
equals 999 right oh wait was it sigh
those options and then 5 10 999 okay to
be honest this is actually pretty cool
chart I'm gonna make this oh why is it
oh there's more than 50 so what's oh
there's a total and then what else is
going on why oh and DC's included to
kind of find out they're saying DC's
estate but okay so it does not equal
total so if there's 50 51 states I guess
we're gonna have a little little guy
over there i'm actually gonna remove I'm
not gonna remove DC so total DC just to
make it oh it's not in so not and so
that way we just have a better you know
a better representation of it plus it
won't work with geo and facets I'm gonna
just assume it doesn't work with it so
we're gonna do that and which is view it
cool so it's economist style we can see
just an overall trend okay one thing
that we could do is like a genome
and we're gonna keep that right there
okay so now I'm gonna look at the actual
geo facet thing um the documentation so
we're gonna install it right here and
then we're gonna install we're gonna oh
no so we're gonna let that install and
then I'm just gonna put that in here and
while we're doing that I'm gonna read
the actual documentation for it so uses
ggplot okay and I guess it's facet geo
instead of facet wrap okay seems pretty
self-explanatory I think we su have to
do steam black-white maybe um let's see
what else there is
so we have to say facet geo state okay
is that it does it maybe just knows okay
so it kind of knows the row columns of
the grid system I guess so fast geo grid
us date I'm gonna use this one cuz this
thing looks better I think this looks
more like America and this one right
it's a little like I don't know I'd know
what this was at first kind of like
Texas to be honest no it doesn't so yeah
we're gonna kind of look at that so
there's an EU thing but you know we're
American and then they have a list of
all of the grids you know maybe we'll
just kind of experiment through the
grits cuz you can see
oh wow us Iowa counties grid oh that's
good I wonder if they use my huh I
wonder if they use my grid that I
created us Iowa counties grid I would
actually like to see that I bet they did
you I mean I don't I don't think they
actually did but we can we didn't hope
it they did okay so I'm gonna remove
that okay
we're gonna put that in there I'm not
sure how it's gonna react with this
theme and well let's just run it and
there we go we have it and we can see
here that actually theme economist is
not great right so let's do that it kind
of does take a long time and then we
have a cool chart where we gotta specify
the scales let's see if the scales doing
facet G Oh interesting
so maybe we might have to add some kind
of scale option scale X facet you uh
facet G oh ok facet grader label move
axes true I'm just gonna read this a
little bit just so I can see if there's
anything that I can actually put into
you know what maybe we'll do I gotta
we'll just do like a center right a
centering or something like that maybe I
don't know because it's it's saying like
Oh some states are our obviously
purchasing more because they've they've
produced beer and stuff like that so I
want to see if there's any free free
scale
scales okay so that there is there is a
good cool so that means we can do scales
equals free why whatever scales equal
equals 3y and we got it okay cool Oh
Rick I wonder if I'll mess with it if I
just say skills equals free
maybe yeah it kind of does mess with it
but you get an idea of it I'm also gonna
do what is it
axis text dot x equals element text
angle equals was it 90 does that do
anything yeah okay I don't really know
if I I think I might just remove the
axis so it cools I think it's actually
element blank there we go so no axis I
would just see the basic time series of
it cool I would clean up the you know
the y-axis but this is something where I
honestly wasn't trying to get it too
much I do want to make it a little bit
smaller so you can see something nice
with it free free why
and there we go we have some type of
chart you know barrels shipped you can
see that just you could see the trends
overall an increase right only thing
that's kind of weird it's like Colorado
I always thought that Colorado was a
heavy beer production which they are but
it seems like other maybe other other
states are kind of taking a lot away
from Colorado cuz that their y-axis is
huge for its scale however it's on a
downward trend for for Y which is
bottles and cans so that they're
producing less bottles and cans but we
can see on the on the other states we're
producing a lot especially with like
Tennessee and stuff like that cool okay
but that really wasn't anything that I
wanted to actually deal with um it's
pretty fun chart I would like to see
that Iowa the Iowa one so how do I get
grid names I want to view that how do I
view a grid head us okay so I'm gonna
look at this grid first because I
actually have a Iowa grid I an Iowa
counties grid so I want to see alamak in
1905 roll call is set I'm gonna see if I
have it um school hex map Iowa cuz I
actually created my own hex map for this
so let's see if that works with it and
I'm just gonna I don't like it nope okay
so it isn't the same thing cool okay so
I don't have to worry about anything
crazy okay but um in this in this video
I actually wanted to focus on this other
thing called profit which is basically
for Facebook's force forecasting model
and what I thought would be interesting
is that we would actually forecast
brewing materials
so looking at brewing materials we
actually get a lot of stuff so first we
should probably do a basic EDA or a bit
or something or just like looking at you
know all the factors and stuff like that
we have like I guess material type
material type and then I got a material
subtype so it's like non grain product
sure hopped up type of stuff of that we
got year month current prior year today
current prior year and we have a data
type I'm gonna do I'm gonna count the
data type I 114 40 okay so we don't
really need data type we don't need the
day type because it's uniform we're
going to account material type and we're
gonna count type two so there's 12 rows
we have types so we have grain type and
non grain type and I think it'd be
interesting to forget forecast
all the types all right so we definitely
want type okay and then I think since
every year month we should be
forecasting purchasing so we'll forecast
our months or like next month current
like what we should be you know I'm
using okay so we're gonna do a select
year month type and then month current I
want to look at this just to make sure
that we don't have to make any like I'm
weeding variables or nice things that
lead or lag variables so month current
current number barrels this this month
do we have a usage number Brewers your
introduction hired numbers your text
Purdue's tech status beer state monster
current number of barrels okay barrel
and then let's see yeah yeah so let's
just forecast like hey man we could do
just beer production make a little bit
easier right whereas where's state all
of your production how many customer
materials
where's Brewers is numbers total brew
now we're gas local forecast monthly I
guess malt and stuff with that usage
okay so we have that and so what's cool
about profit is it's pretty it's pretty
high-level interface
um it it really is simple to use when I
was looking at the documentation it just
it just takes in basically two variables
a data and like a Y hat or a Y
prediction variable so you just kind of
give it year-month-day date and yeah
that's basically and then oh why so what
that's what we're gonna do we're gonna
actually just I'm gonna say let's see
here
first since if we notice our month right
it doesn't hat for your month day dates
you actually have to have a like a
leading zero and the Singler integers so
we're gonna just change that so we'll
say month equals if else month is less
than 10 so we don't need to add a
leading 0 we'll just say paste 0 a month
except
no separation else will do month as that
character right there so we have it for
each month and we added a
leading leading zero and then we're
gonna do a mutate will say a year equals
as dot character year here and then
we'll say D s equals pasted year month
oh one set equals that so what we're
doing right now is I'm saying like since
we don't have a day we're just gonna try
to forecast like we'll just say Oh
beginning of the month we're gonna try
to forecast for opinion a month this is
something that's totally I mean I don't
really know this data very well um cuz
it's like month current right so with
production it could be end of month or
being it being a mouth I don't really
know how it goes for that but that's
what we're gonna do and then we're gonna
format this as dot date right then we
have a date we have a year month date
after converting all that stuff and it
was only with one mutate function okay
so now we're just gonna select the S
type will select actually type D s and
month current we're gonna call this our
model data cool all right so if we look
at this will say account type we want to
make basically a model for each product
each production type so how we're gonna
do this is it's a little bit odd because
with like you could make a linear model
and this would be easy where you just to
like nest - type right and then you'd
kind of like make a linear model you
like a map BF model equals LM was it
and then you'd be icon a month current
and then it'd be D Estacada equals data
right it'd be something like that oops
so Matt TBL would be something like that
but that's not really what we want to do
so we so if we're gonna do this instead
because the profit object actually takes
something else so we're gonna have to do
kind of like basically a partitioning of
the data so let's just start this first
if we count if we know that there's ten
ten different types so we're gonna have
to go through it ten times and just like
take out each type and make a model so
we're gonna do that so we're gonna do a
for I and one through ten and I'm gonna
make I'm actually gonna do something so
it makes it a little bit easier so
select a type and I'm gonna use distinct
I used to use unique a lot um I guess
unique isn't as efficient as a sting so
I'm just gonna do that all so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna actually add a
name to it so it's so I can have like a
shorthand for it so I'll say malt
you know I'll cap I said why not
malt corn rice barley wheat total green
products total grain sugar hops which is
hops by the most important hops extract
and I'm gonna hops and then dry and then
lastly we'll say
other corn what's here oh man I've had
to pause this for a second
hey oh I actually came back and was
recording and finished up this actual
tight trees a video however actually
found out that my mic was turned off so
I had a scrapped you know the half of
the video but I decided I'm gonna come
back here and finish it up so when I
came when I when I came back I finished
up the key that would allow me to
basically have a simpler name just for
some modeling purposes additionally I
want to just kind of plot out the actual
production stuff so the other product
I'm assuming product usage or this
monthly um inventory so we can kind of
see how it it is there are some seasonal
things if you see how it's like kind of
spirally or it's it's kind of like
digging zig and zag in'
so uh that's pretty that's pretty
interesting there's some seasonal some
seasonal patterns going on there's also
a lot of like outliers or like I'm just
up where there's a huge amount of usage
it might actually be a typo or I guess
scraping air but I'm not really sure so
now we're actually gonna load up the
profit package and when I was looking at
it I decided that I'm just gonna do it
kind of like the dirty way where I'm
gonna create a model results data frame
which will be empty and I'll basically
gather all of our model stuff so in this
eye so in this chunk I actually created
a for loop from 1 to 12 and I did that
because our key has 12 rows so there's
12 different data sets and I'm
essentially subsetting the data through
each specific um key or type and
creating a model from that so I'm
basically making these like micro level
models and within this for loop I I
create a generic variable called model
where I take a model data filter it
using the given index of the key type so
since I'm gonna do 4 I and 1 through 12
I'm just gonna go
each item in descending order one one by
one so it's just gonna say okay I'm
gonna we're gonna filter out all
products that are malt and malt product
products for the first iteration and I'm
gonna just select the s and the month on
the month current and I'm gonna format
to Y because that's what profit needs
and will create the profit model I also
use this really handy function if you
use a lot of for loops it's called a
sign and basically you copy that um
whatever object you want to copy and
then you would give it a new name so in
this case I'm just gonna take the name
so I would say like oh I'm gonna make a
malt model so let's say model and we
have our malt profit model and now I'm
gonna make a and then I made a future
which I'm gonna make a future data frame
where I'm gonna basically have it
predict on the next three periods and I
specify three periods and these periods
would then be in this case months on the
next three months and I trust three
months because it kind of makes the most
sense because you don't really want to
plan your your I guess your your
purchasing for inventory like six months
in ahead of time it was probably easier
to do three or even probably even to one
month one or two months so that three
months was fine I then create I then
apply the model so I predicted the model
with the future data so what I'll do is
basically fit the data to what we've
already seen and then also predict the
next three periods I select the date y
hat Y hat upper and Y hat lower so we
get some upper and lower bounds for our
predictions and then I just kind of add
a type so we know our result and what
what's the corresponding Y hats or in
values are for for each model also
format the date and then I joined the
model data and in this case I'm gonna
join the model data because I want to
compare the actual actual inventory with
the predicted inventory um internally I
then do our bind where I'm gonna just
essentially append the the data set to
the model results so I'm gonna run that
it's gonna take like I don't know about
23 seconds which is pretty good because
I'm saying I'm training like 12 model
too
forecasting models over like I don't
know I you know a few years so then we
get these um some some messages it says
we're not doing weekly seasonality or
daily seasonality that's because we
don't really have we only have monthly
in Euro data and we can also override it
if we want to so I'm gonna plot the
model results where I basically say the
black line is the actual data and then
the red the red line you can't really
see it very well but the right-aligned
or that the colored line is what the
model is predicting and though the the
raine that the intervals are the y upper
and wild lowers so you can see it's
actually fitting it pretty well I then
decided that I want to actually compare
my predictions with the actual and the
predicted so I do a just comparison plot
or on stage it's kind of just comparing
the residuals and a more interpret
manner for people who aren't really used
to looking at residuals where I fit Y
the y axis with the actual values and
the x axis with their predictive values
and I throw in a a a random just a line
that's fitted with a slope of one so
ideally we'd want all these points to be
on the black line but honestly if we saw
it all on the black line that that might
kind of indicate there's some
overfitting however so we kind of just
want to beat wanted to be around the
line because that means it perfectly
predicted it so if it's above the black
line it means it's over predicting if
it's under than one it's under
predicting and we don't want it to be um
on one on an upper half or the lower
half we want to kind of be in the middle
you know we don't have to be biased
towards one end okay so we can see here
and it hops most of the data center
around here
however there's all watching like these
outliers and I think that's fine I
wouldn't want to basically be predicting
on these outliers so looking at that
this isn't too good you can see this
huge gap where it's just like it's kind
of weird how there's like no interval in
I was correctly predicted in this range
again in this room again here it's kind
of fun because there seems to huge
variances in total usage so if you my
going in uh I create another plot to
create another but where I'm basically
showing where the points are the actual
um monthly values and the lion is the
fitted y hat so you can see how it's
really trying to capture always seasonal
patterns it's it's kind of like um spiky
and you can really see it fit really
well with malt and malt products see how
it's really capturing these seasonal
patterns and then one hits zero it
really like you know skyrockets down and
still trying to cash I got seasonality
effect same with this one
um the other it really has it's like
kind of like crest shape that with some
seasonal issues with seasonal stuff okay
and then finally just like a generic you
know a pressure to started with this
where it's just showing the line the Y
hat and the actual and seeing its
interactions and seeing how how its
trying to predict these actual trends
cool and then I did kind of a residual
distribution plot where I kind wanted to
see like oh I wonder how much what the
distributions of it over overestimating
or underestimating so blue is when the
residuals or the difference is
overestimating and the red is when the
difference is under estimating alright
so we can see that see the distributions
and you see right here like it
definitely I don't know I want to make
any craziness but you can see how it's
really over fitting the overestimating
some of these total green products of
sugar in stirrups okay and now to like
the rule of fun stuff so I was thinking
about something where oh okay
I wanted to create like and be kind of
cool to create like Oh what to make like
a micro some micro forecasting models
right we already was mess we were
already messing with the UM the the
facet
was it geo facet pot with state beer
production but what we wouldn't be cool
if we could actually do like kind of a
forecasted state beer production right
so that's basically what I was doing
right here first so I said okay and in
this case I did bottles and cans but
let's look at here
I think bottles and cans are the most
used so it's the bottles and cans it Y
was gonna is a red so makes sense I
think most people drink from bottles and
cans anyways especially the corona bread
is going on now so I said okay we're
gonna filter out bottles and cans we're
gonna select state year and barrels and
then we're just gonna mutate this we're
um since its I believe uh like annual
data right since since its annual data
we're just gonna try to forecast the
beginning of every year definitely not
like a good III wouldn't I probably want
to do that I'm also I knew more about it
but if I knew more about I would
probably have a better answer but I just
decided to do the first of the year you
always do end of the year pretty much
the same thing because we're the same
distances away like New Year's Eve and
January first or you know a basically
the same day so I'm just gonna run this
work okay so we have all this we're
gonna group by state and it was like
okay so now I'll just kind of just use
the model like the profit function as
the sounds just like you know a mutate
func in a mutate so we can't really use
mutate we gotta use do so we're doing
all these like funky little functions
we're gonna just have to do a a better
way to do it more like um looser way to
do it where it's not gonna try to have
any exceptions or anything like that so
I say okay we're gonna make a model
object and in that model object we're
just gonna give it our data since we
know it's gonna grouped it's a say-so so
for every state we're saying give you
this data cool and then finally we're
gonna make a future data frame with our
already made model and we're gonna try
to predict the next two years
then we're gonna predict with our given
model and our future data our results
and when I was looking at this I I
realized that we could actually do that
use the do function I didn't think we
could do use the do function at the
beginning when I I made made the
original profit curves so like for here
I could actually have done just a group
I type and then a do model so we don't
want need the Forbes will say all the
way of doing was it I'm micro level
models right so we can just use a do
function right so AZ we have a group
data right we're gonna make a model with
every group two data we're gonna make a
future data set which will be nested and
then we're going to create a results
data set so we're gonna enter that in
and it's gonna take a while alright
because we're trying to predict like
fifty two states for balls and can
production given even though we don't
really have alright a lot of data it's
only about you know like five or six I
think 10 years only ten in years ten
years or so um it will take a little
while yeah so we have like 10 we have
like 10 years of data no no we know 10
years a day we have a I don't know what
we don't really like that much data for
it so we're just gonna run this let it
go
so we're almost done we're almost done I
know it also comes with this little
little handy progress tracking bar so
that's pretty that's pretty nice you
know those those people I face of car
are pretty pretty smart people okay so
what do we have here now so we have 52
rows and we have a nested model a nested
future a nested future data frame
containing you know our data that we're
trying to predict or like you know our
dates that we would predict and then we
have our actual results okay so we're
just gonna unnecessary state D s y hat Y
hat upper and Y hat lawyer
okay so we have all the predictions for
these states and we're also gonna I
guess yeah and then we're just gonna
ggplot it out x equals d s y equals y
hat color eco state plus genome line
place genome I will say I'm trying to
think of how how should I visualize it I
kind of do like the ribbon chart so I I
kind of do like this ribbon chart right
here so we're gonna do that so so plus
GM ribbon and we'll say a is y max it
goes y hat upper Y min equals y hat
lower plus okay
and then and also we're gonna do I'm
gonna do out for a really small alpha so
I'll say alpha equal alpha equals like
0.1 so I'm just gonna run that first
just to make just to see if I like the
alpha for it
oh I know you need the fill equals state
okay so I'm actually a changes so I'm
gonna make the color equal to black okay
oh okay
coffee clothes black hey make a make
though I'm gonna make that and we'll
worry about this later okay so fat G
Fassett geo spies state and once a grid
equals US state grid two scales equals
free okay and then I'm gonna do theme
legend dot position those none
and I'm gonna do a big dot height equals
13 fig dot with a width equals 15
okay hmm
what's going on here oh okay so the
years are a little off so I got an idea
I'm gonna make I'm gonna do a mutate to
say mutate
d s equals TS minus - mm okay not sure
why it's doing that
so okay okay well so we have that and
I'm going to do a plus G labs and say
title equals forecasted was it what was
it a beer can beer bottle and can bottle
and can what it's called
production yeah forecast a Bock and
Canford function and then we'll say a
subtitle
using proc profit well and I'll say
[Music]
micro level forecasting forecasting
using profit cool I'm not sure why it's
getting cut off like that that's kind of
annoying let's see here
hmm oh well I'm gonna shoot you G save
and save forecast dot pedia up cut PDF
pot equals last plot and then with
equals 32 high equals 18 units equals
inches we'll save that I'm gonna go
where is it
cut your Tuesday forecast and we'll view
it nope there we go
forecasted forecasted beverage deals
with with profit which is a little bit
bigger but you know what it is what it
is so yeah I hope you learned a little
bit more about like forecasting and
basically how to make micro level models
it's actually pretty simple you just
kind of have to switch out on the mutate
function with do so yeah hopefully I'll
see you next week and uh yeah Teddy on